- And I didn't know!
- Alright, we are live!
Welcome, everybody, to
another YouTube Hangout!
I'm pumped to be here, with
my friend, Daniel DiPiazza.
Daniel, welcome aboard, man.
- [Daniel] Oh, hey man.
Thanks for having me.
I just found out something
about you I didn't know,
and you just threw it on me.
It's like a bucket of cold water.
I didn't know--
- [Evan] What's that?
- You're Canadian.
- [Evan] Oh.
That's a bucket of, like, amazing water.
(stammers) That's tears from, not tears,
that's like joy from the Heaven's water.
- [Daniel] It's a bucket of maple syrup.
- [Evan] There you go!
Nice, that's a sticky bucket, though.
- Warm and sticky.
(Daniel laughing)
- So, Daniel's a friend.
Daniel has a website, Rich20Something.
He's got a new book that
is dropping, on Tuesday,
called Rich20Something.
Daniel's built three different businesses,
to a 100,000 dollars plus, in revenue,
with zero setup capital,
so it wasn't just buyin' his customers.
And he's going to share
some of his secrets,
some of his strategies,
to help you guys,
entrepreneurs startin' up.
Tryin' to get some
traction with your company.
- [Daniel] Yeah!
Oh, yeah.
- Daniel, tell us,
quickly, about the book,
what's in it, what people
can expect from it,
and then, we'll get to questions
comin' in from the audience as well.
- [Daniel] Well, look, okay.
So, first of all, I just
want to preference this
with saying that, we're changing
our company rhetoric now.
I don't want anybody
else, ever again, to say,
three businesses, to 100K,
with no startup capital,
because, no, you don't need,
you don't need startup capital
to get to 100K.
I...
Someone took that piece of language,
and it's now proliferated
across the Internet.
I don't know where it
came from, but anyway,
this is a good point,
because in the book, I'll
teach you how to get to a 100K,
without startup capital.
It's not hard.
And the cool thing about
this book, Rich20Something,
is that, really, it's like this,
it's like a, it's like one of
those black and white cookies.
You ever have one of those at the store?
It's like a black and white cookie?
- [Evan] Like an Oreo?
- No, no!
It's like, dual-sided.
Like, half-black, half-white.
You ever seen those before?
- I've never seen that.
I'm Canadian, man.
We don't have half-black,
half-white cookies. (laughs)
- That's me!
So, okay, so on the one side,
it's like my personal story
about how I built businesses,
how I overcame a lot
of the mental barriers
that I had to wrestle with,
comin' out of college,
figuring out what my
destiny was going to be,
quote-unquote, destiny.
And then, the other half is the tactical,
meaty, strategic side.
So, what's great about this book,
is that it's not just a
do-this-then-that manual,
and it's not just like
a wishy-washy memoir,
it's really a solid, it's a solid journey
through what I had to go through,
to start multiple, different
businesses, where I was...
Learned how to find clients,
learned how to show that I
had skills I could provide,
and understanding the mental game,
and then also the tactical game, so, like,
how do you pick a business
that you know is going to work?
How do you find something that you know,
that there's a new marketplace for?
How do you pitch clients, and find them?
How do you press yourself?
And so, it's kind of
like this really cool mix
of the real world,
versus a tactical world.
- [Evan] I like it.
And it comes out on Tuesday.
- [Daniel] May 2nd, yeah.
Tuesday.
- [Evan] May, I love it.
So, well, I want to get some questions,
and the audience as well,
but before doing that, we've listed this
as how to start an epic business.
So, give us, give Believe
Nation a couple steps
on what they need to do,
to start an epic business.
- [Daniel] Alright, Believe Nation.
Here's the first thing.
You have to make sure
that there is a demand
for your business, first,
because I think one of the biggest things,
and actually, I'm at Fort Bragg right now,
and so, I'm talking to veterans
about starting businesses,
and one of the big things
that they have trouble with,
is thinking, man, if I leave the security
of either, my job with the army,
or some sort of regular nine-to-five job,
I don't want to take the
risk of starting a business,
'cause it could fail.
And this is a problem
a lot of people have,
this mental barrier of, if
I start, it's going to fail.
But, there are ways to make sure
that it's a good idea, before
you invest time and money,
and ways to, almost, invest no money.
So, here's what I'd recommend.
First of all, make sure that
the idea that you want to do
is already being done by someone else,
because that will give you, at least,
a decent amount of foresight
into what is, potentially,
your level of success.
What I like to do, and I'm just,
I'm just being practical with this.
I like to look at the things
that are already trending,
and find a skill that I can pick,
to start the business with.
So, I'll go on somewhere, like...
Well, now, it's called Upwork,
and I'll look at all the
different things that they list,
everything from graphic
design, to video editing,
to web development, to virtual assistant.
And I'll see what types
of jobs are listed,
and I'll think, which of these
skills would I like to learn?
And I'll see that there
are multiple people asking
for these things,
or multiple people that are
paying for these services.
I'll say, hey, there might
be a business model here,
and rather than trying
to read about the wheel,
I'll see what people are asking for first,
and I'll make sure that there's a market,
and then I'll go start it,
'cause I know that there's clients,
and a market base for it, first.
- [Evan] Got it.
- So, that's the first step,
making sure that there's
a solid market for it.
The next step is...
Making sure that the market
actually has the amount
of money that you want,
to make sure that you can
make the type of money
that you need.
And, remember,
that when you're first
starting your business,
and this is my philosophy, okay?
Everyone, if you talk to Mark Zuckerberg,
he has a different philosophy.
My philosophy, is start with
a service, because it's easy,
and it's quick.
So, I like to think, okay.
What can I do now,
to gradually replace
my nine-to-five income?
So, I look at these jobs,
let's say we're going back
to the Upwork example,
and I'm finding these skills,
I'm listing these things,
I'm finding something that I
can do, and think to myself,
alright, well, I see
that these jobs are going
for like, maybe 500, to
a thousand dollars a job.
Maybe, I can get a few of these,
and it doesn't have to
be on the upper platform,
but it can be, you can find
clients out in the wild.
So, alright.
If I can get a few of these clients...
If I can start to pay for my
regular, day-to-day bills,
with this side hustle work,
I can scale it up overtime.
You don't need to quit your job,
in order to start a new business.
You can do both at the same time,
and start something on the side,
and then, once your side
income gets to about
60, 70 percent of what your daily,
like your monthly take-home is,
then, you're thinking to yourself,
oh, well, really, the only
thing holding me back now,
is the time factor.
And since you're still putting
time into your nine-to-five,
you can eventually switch
gears, and move full-time,
into whatever freelance business you pick.
And then, the third thing
I would think about,
when starting a new business,
to make sure it works,
is what can you do differently, or better?
So, let's say you went onto a job,
where it's like to find what was popular.
You found something popular.
You got a few clients.
You made a little bit of money.
Now, you want to differentiate a bit,
and find something that
you can do differently,
and, or better.
One of my students, Micah,
is a personal trainer,
and rather than just
be a standard trainer,
one thing that he does,
is different, or better,
is he goes to people's houses,
rather than having them come to him,
and even has a MM fitness van,
that he wrapped with stickers,
so you can see, his face,
is like flexing on the side of the van.
And he comes with all of his equipment.
I think he even has little workout snacks,
for before and after.
So, just a little, simple
tweak in the service,
that makes it completely unique,
and allows him to charge more, right?
- [Evan] I like it!
- [Daniel] Yeah!
- Cool, so...
People that are writin' in the comments
are liking the value,
they're taking notes.
Every step, they're taking notes.
Liard was saying, that they have to,
"We have to get you a
black and white cookie."
What's with this black and white cookie?
- Have you ever been
to an American bakery?
Come on.
- [Evan] This is a standard thing?
You go into any American bakery, and you,
I've been to American bakeries.
I've never seen a black and white cookie.
- I can't speak for every
black and white cookie,
or ever black and white person.
All I can say, is... (laughs)
All I can say, is that they're delicious.
- [Evan] Alright.
I like it.
I will test it out.
Next time I go to an American bakery,
I'm going to channel my Daniel,
and try to find some
black and white cookies.
Take me through, how many
chapters are in the book?
- Man, is it sad that I
have to look at my own book
to tell you?
I think it's ten.
- [Evan] Ten.
- Ten, yeah.
It's a nice, round number.
- Just for like some high-level overview,
give me the chapter title...
And a main thought from that chapter.
- [Daniel] Are you really
quizzing me on my own book?
Do you know, you know that I don't even--
- [Evan] We can look at it!
You got it in front of you!
Look, look, chapter one is this!
Read it!
- [Daniel] Okay, just making sure,
'cause I really, 'cause you know,
it's so funny, when you
write something like this,
I mean, I wrote every single word.
But afterwards, it's like, whoa.
Did I write all that?
That's weird!
You know?
- [Evan] I just want to get a sense
from what we're going to get from it.
- Okay, so...
- What's in each section?
So, there's ten chapters, like the--
- [Daniel] There's ten chapters.
There's ten chapters, broken
into three sections, right?
Classical story arc, okay?
So, first section, which
is the first few chapters,
is preparing for the journey, right?
Getting ready to go on this journey.
The first part of the book
is all about the mental stuff
that you need to clear out,
before you can start the business,
because, again, just a simple
example of the barriers
about a business being very risky,
or another one we get a lot
is, "I don't have any ideas.
"I can't start a business,
unless I have an idea."
The first few chapters of the book
deal with how to overcome
these really common,
but very pernicious mental barriers,
because we know
that a lot of the games
we play with ourselves
are like weird, defense mechanisms,
to get us to not, to not fail, right?
But, we need to be able
to surpass those steps of limitations.
I mean, look at all the people
on your wall behind you.
You know, you got Jobs.
I know you have Kanye
back there somewhere.
All of these guys are people
who were able to master their mindset,
and push past the fear complex.
And so, we spend a lot of time
talking about how to overcome these fears,
and we also go through a
lot of different scenarios,
to try to completely
make some of these fears
seem irrational.
So, we go through different exercises
to make those seem irrational,
and how to stop
procrastinating with yourself.
So, that's the first thing.
Second thing, second phase,
which is like the middle chapters
of the book we move into,
strategy and tactics.
So, what are the specific
ways to start the business?
What's my philosophy behind it?
So, we go through the freelancing thing.
We go through how to scale up,
from zero, to six figures,
just with a service-based business.
And then, we also talk about
how to move into online world.
So, how to go from, I'm just
performing this whole service.
Hey, it's Daniel!
I'm here to, like, personal train you!
To, hey, it's Daniel.
Now, I'm online, and I
have a company, right?
Two different things.
We talk about that transition.
And the third phase of the book is like,
kind of the aftermath,
and this is a lot of the
stuff I had to learn, too,
along the way.
Okay, you're makin' a
little bit of money, now.
How do you deal with the,
with some of the weird things
that come up as an entrepreneur.
How do you stay focused?
How do you, how do you
adjust your mindset,
to the fact that you're makin'
a little bit more money now,
but you have to really be your own boss.
What does that mean?
And so, the third
section talks about that,
and it kind of wraps it up.
- [Evan] I like it.
Cool.
Well, let's get to some questions
here, from the live chat.
You guys have questions for Daniel.
Leave it there.
I know we already got a
ton of people chiming in.
BestUPro.
"Are you familiar with the concept
"of pulling from both sides, by Gary V?
"And what are your thoughts?"
Are you familiar with that,
pulling from both sides?
- I'm not.
Do you know who that is, Evan?
- [Evan] I'm not super familiar.
I want to say it's his
clouds and dirt idea,
where it's, the clouds
is like the strategy,
and the big picture stuff, but
then, also, doing the work.
- Right.
- Hustling everyday.
But, I don't want to say
that that's necessarily
pulling from both sides.
- [Daniel] It sounds good.
- [Evan] Anyway, okay.
If you you give us some more
clarity on that, BestUPro,
then maybe we can answer it for you.
Next.
Pervina.
"How much time should we
spend assessing the demands?"
So, back to what you were
talking, with the beginning,
assess the demand.
How do people go about it?
You were talking about Upwork.
And then, how much time should
they spend on that part?
- [Daniel] Yeah, so just to be clear,
this is a very good
example for an interview,
because it's a very clear
example of how to find ideas.
But, at the same time,
Upwork is a super simple,
but only one example,
of how to find work.
In terms of how to assess the demand,
I think a few things
have to come into play.
First of all, just know that the process
of you looking out in the
world, and asking yourself,
is this a liable business model?
It is part of that process.
And if you go through this process,
another way would be to
look at Yelp reviews,
or to go on Amazon,
and see what people are complaining about,
and see where there are paying points.
As you go through this process,
you're going to become better at assessing
what's real, what's a real
need, versus what's a...
Noise.
What's just static.
And, you might go
through a few iterations,
of a couple different business ideas,
that you think are good,
and they seem to have
some sort of relevance.
And then, you start testing them,
and no one really wants that.
And that would be okay.
It would be okay, if you
didn't hit a home run,
out of the park, the first time,
because as an entrepreneur,
a lot of this comes down to testing.
And so, you're building the skillset
of identifying a good idea.
And that's why, a lot of times,
when you see really sharp entrepreneurs,
men and women who get good at business,
they can instantly assess an idea.
One of my friends, Lori
Greiner, from Shark Tank,
has this whole concept,
called hero or zero.
And she can instantly tell,
I don't know how accurate she is,
but she seems to be pretty accurate.
She's doing well on the show.
She can instantly tell
whether their business idea's
going to be good, or not.
And I think that comes
with time, and experience.
So, it's okay if you spend
a little bit of a time,
and it flops,
or a lot of bit of time, and it does well.
Just find an idea, and don't
wait too long to iterate,
because what really stops you,
is the paralysis by analysis, you know?
Spend a few days looking it up.
See if it's a good fit.
And then, start planting out some seeds.
- [Evan] Cool.
So, when we were talkin' about,
before you were sayin',
makin' that transition
from a full-time job,
to your side hustle making
that your full-time thing.
And what was the percentage
you gave it, 60 percent,
70 percent?
- I say it's 70, yeah.
- [Evan] So, when you're
making 60, to 70 percent
of your income, from your side hustle,
then you quit, and you go
full-in on your business...
You got a question comin'
in from Valley, saying,
and this is great time management,
"How can I start a business,
"if I work 12 hours at
my job, already, a day?"
- [Daniel] I mean, okay.
So, there's multiple, different
ways to think about this.
The first way, is just like
the very, in your face,
Gary V-type of like,
it's the second shift.
It's the other seven-to-two,
where it's like, you get home,
you do your thing with your family,
and you go back to work.
There is that.
I mean, that always is an option.
But, I think that can burn
you out, after a while.
So, you have to really be able to assess
how important it is, the business, to you?
It is a valid, working 12
hours a day, is a valid thing,
and you do have to sleep.
I get it.
But, at the end of the day, you know,
if you can put in, at least,
one-to-two hours per day,
and I would actually say,
try to find one block,
where you can do that.
Four 30-minute blocks
is not the same thing
as one two-hour block.
So, if you could find,
even a one-hour block,
to get some good work done,
once a day is still seven hours a week,
especially on the weekends, too.
Remember the weekends,
you should be be able to work with 'em,
an hour on the weekends.
And remember, that if you can
go into that one-hour block,
with a plan of what you're going to do,
the hour will be more effective.
A lot of times, it takes
us 30-to-40 minutes,
just to like clarify what we need to do.
So, don't go into the block of time,
if you only have a little bit of time,
don't go into the time with no plan.
Spend some time, during your work day.
I'm sure you have 15 minutes
during your work day,
to plot out what you're going to do
when you get to your power hour,
or whatever you want to call it,
and go in there, crunch for an hour,
and I think seven-to-ten hours a week
is not hard to squeeze out.
If you really peek at it,
that's 40, 40 hours a month.
You can do something with that.
- Yeah.
I think, too...
What are you doing, during your job?
I think a lot people take a job
that they're not learning anything.
Or, if you want to, if you want to grow,
like, can you take a job,
where you're learning some of the skills
you'll need to take into
your business as well.
- [Daniel] Or, where you
have access to a computer,
where you can kind of just
do your own thing sometimes.
(Evan laughing)
I mean, where we are, and
it's the truth, you know?
- Alright.
I like it.
Listen, the security guard at my building
likes to overnight.
- [Daniel] Of course!
- Do his thing, so...
- He better be workin' on Shopify store,
if you're a security guard!
- [Evan] Alright, next up, Dion!
"How can you deal with failure,
"and still move forward into
what you want to become?"
So, how do you deal with
failure, and still move forward?
- [Daniel] Why is failure
seen as this poisonous event?
The only problem with failure is that
it's seen as very negative.
But, what is the problem with that?
I don't understand, like,
let's change the narrative on failure.
Let's not talking about
dealing with failure.
Let's change our perspective,
on whether failure is bad,
or not.
There's a bunch of things
I'm failing at right now.
You can have a book out,
about how to start a successful business,
and still have trouble in business.
You know, because every time you level up,
you have to learn new stuff.
So, you're going to fail all the time.
The only way that you're
not going to fail,
is if you don't do anything,
which is, in itself, a failure.
There's no...
We can go meta on you,
and say that, like, the human
race is constantly failing.
That's why, you know, we're
constantly trying to evolve,
and change.
I mean, so, there's
nothing wrong with failure.
I think that you just need to learn that,
that uncomfortable feeling that you get,
when you fail at something,
is just your ego, trying to protect you.
But, you don't need protection.
You're fine.
Just keep going.
- People are saying, "Love
that answer about failure.
"Great answer about failure."
Yeah, fail more!
- But, you know what?
But, let me just urge anyone
who's watching right now.
It's also, be careful of
the trendy buzzword stuff,
like hustle, authenticity, failure.
These become buzzwords.
But, I really want you
to take that to heart.
Outside of the inspirational stuff,
really take to heart what it means
to be able to be resilient, and try again.
There's nothing, there's
no personal attachment
to you having some sort of,
struggling with something.
You struggling with something
isn't an indemnification
on your personal being.
You having some sort of challenge,
that you're struggling to overcome,
doesn't mean that you,
personally, are a failure.
This is an event.
So, I think that if we can all
get a little bit less attached
to the results of things,
it wouldn't be so painful.
And then, we wouldn't be
so scared to try, you know?
- [Evan] I like it.
I like it.
Daniel going meta on us.
You can go meta anytime, man.
I like it.
Let's try and keep up with the chat!
You guys are going nuts!
I love it!
Let's see, what else.
Valley is asking,
"How important, do you
think, networking is
"for an online business?"
- Well, there are two things,
that you need to know.
Networking is, obviously, very important.
But, the good thing is that
most people think that,
it's kind of the same thing as,
oh, you have to have money, to make money.
Yes.
But, there's a little asterisk here.
So, it is really helpful, in business,
to have already built up a network,
because, then, they can help you.
But, as you go into business,
you're going to network
with people naturally,
as long as you put yourself out there.
So, I like to think of,
especially online business,
I don't know about
other areas of business,
but I think especially online...
Have I ever told you this
analogy before, Evan?
It's like high school classes, okay?
Depending on what year you start,
everyone that starts with you,
within a two, or three year period,
you guys are in the
same high school class.
And you guys help each other.
Because the people who keep
going, rise up the ranks,
and we just had our first book
pretty close to each other.
So, we're in a similar class.
I think you have more
followers on one platform,
I have more followers on another platform,
and a book out on similar times.
We're kind of in the same
high school class here.
Now, there are other people
who we probably look up to,
who are like the juniors, and the seniors.
I feel like I'm a sophomore, okay?
And they have more
followers, more traction,
they've had more time in the game.
But, we're networking
with each other right now.
So, don't worry about
trying to always network
with the big guys at the top,
because you'll get there eventually.
Network with people who
are your level right now,
but who are doing things.
And as you guys keep rising,
you guys will see, that in five years,
oh crap, you're both doing great work,
and you've been spending all this time
talking to each other.
All my friends, who are
going to promote this book,
I've known them since day one.
They're not new friends.
So, start now, but don't worry about
always shooting for the top, first.
Just do great work where you're at,
and then, rise to the
top, with your peers.
- [Evan] I like it.
The high school class analogy.
So, I like that.
- I'm not a freshman, though.
I am not a freshman anymore.
(Evan laughing)
I'm out of that.
- [Evan] Okay, Eric wants
to go super specific.
Let's see what we got here.
"Daniel, can you please talk
about how to start a tea shop?
"Any advice would be awesome."
- [Daniel] Okay.
So, oh, we're talkin' like...
Like, consumable tea, right, like...
- [Evan] I'm assuming, I'm assuming.
- Okay, so, this is a good one.
There are a couple
different ways to do it.
So, the first thing I think of,
is you have to have a unique angle,
because that market is,
I mean, all the markets
are kind of flooded.
So, what's your unique angle?
I have one of my students...
Who has a tea company
called Jordan and Jane's,
and her name is Jordan, and
Jane refers to Mary Jane,
which is like cannabis-infused tea.
But, it's not, I don't
think it's psychoactive,
'cause she's in Colorado.
But, I don't think it's psychoactive.
I think it's more of just like...
Like, hemp tea, right?
But, that is a unique angle,
because there's a lot of
different health properties
associated with hemp and cannabis.
So, she has a unique angle,
where she adds very nice flavors to it.
Plus, there's the cannabis angle.
So, I would try to find an angle.
If you look online now, on Instagram,
a lot of these fitness models
are doing this skinny tea thing,
where this tea, this detox tea cleanse.
Are you in that world, Evan?
Do you know about that?
- [Evan] No.
- [Daniel] Okay, this is
a whole world of girls
who want to like get
rid of the tummy bloat.
So, it's called Skinny Tummy Tea,
and they have it in the shaker,
and I don't know if it
works, I haven't tried it.
But, apparently, you drink it,
and it just gets rid of
the digestive issues,
and the bloats.
So, that's another type of tea,
where you have to have a
specific purpose for it.
If you're just going to make green tea,
you know, I think Earl's got you covered.
Like, Earl Grey tea is good.
Like, Lipton has got that market.
So, try to go for something
specific in niche,
so that you can stand out in a way,
where even if you only capture
one percent of the market,
or half the percent, or a quarter percent,
they're really enthusiastic
quarter percent.
- [Evan] Alright.
I like it.
Super tactical.
- [Daniel] Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam!
- [Evan] Next up!
"Hey, Daniel!"
- [Daniel] Hey!
- "Why are startups not
usually successful?"
- [Daniel] Is that true?
Is that true?
You know what?
I would challenge--
- [Evan] We're going to go meta.
We're going to go meta, again.
Here it comes!
- Okay.
But, here's a new train of thought
that I've been playing with.
And so, I'm going to debut
this on your show, okay Evan?
- [Evan] Alright.
I like it.
- [Daniel] This is a new,
a new piece of thought
leadership I've been developing.
We need to start asking better questions,
because the questions that we ask
create the answers that we receive.
And so, when you ask a question like
why aren't startups successful,
you're going to get a lot of
reasons why they're not successful,
and you're going to naturally
return these things.
Maxwell Maltz wrote a book
called Psycho-Cybernetics,
where he talks about using
the reticular activation system.
And I don't know if this is pseudoscience,
but I just remember the terminology.
Basically, the idea is,
if you think of a problem backwards,
you can find the solution.
Well, if you think about the problem,
like why don't things work,
you're going to think of all
the reasons why it doesn't work.
So, I would challenge you,
rather than focusing on that,
and I'm not blowing off the answer,
but I would say, think
about why startups do work,
and focus on that, and just do that.
The main reason why they don't work,
is for a few reasons.
One, because the founders
just don't want to keep going.
It's really hard.
I think that's the number one reason.
But also, obviously, there
are also market issues,
market fit, money.
You know, people can get
screwed over by a partner.
All these things can happen,
but at the end of the
day, it's really hard,
just business is very hard.
And if you get lucky in the beginning,
you're going to need to build
skill to backup that luck.
If you have skill in the beginning,
you're still going to need some
luck, to get you to the top.
You need skill and luck.
And the only way you get
skill and luck, is with time.
So, if you don't put in the time,
you won't get those two
attributes, skill and luck,
and you're just going to fall apart.
So, rather than think about
why it's not going to work,
find the reasons why businesses
do work, and emulate that.
Don't run from what you don't want.
Run towards what you do want.
- [Evan] I like it!
The debut!
- [Daniel] Boom, boom, boom, boom!
- You should go heavy on that stuff, man.
I like it.
- [Daniel] Boom.
- SanFranMan is saying,
"Daniel, love your website!"
You guys can check that
out, Rich20Something.com.
"I have a lot of different
potential business ideas.
"Can you talk about focusing on,
"and choosing a single
idea to go all in on,
"and start your business?"
- [Daniel] Yeah, this is a good one.
And you know what's funny, Evan?
I'll tell you this.
Having too many ideas
is almost more painful
than having no ideas, right?
Because you feel like,
man, all of these could be,
you're watching Shark Tank,
and you're like, man, all three of,
three of those five inventions
I've already had in my head,
and I haven't done anything with it.
Picking one idea, out of the three,
let's say you have three ideas...
I think we all kind of,
in the back of our heads,
know which idea is usually the best.
I think we all kind of know.
I think that when we have multiple ideas,
some of the competing ideas that we have
are things that are like
our passion projects,
and our fantasies.
And some of the ones, that we
know are going to be the ones,
are going to be the most successful.
I would say, pick the one,
as the lowest hanging fruit
in the beginning,
with the lowest startup capital,
and the lowest amount of inherent risk,
which is why I always like a service,
'cause if you don't like the service,
you can always quit it.
There's no inventory.
There's no systems to shut down.
It's just you.
And then, also remember,
that whatever you do now,
doesn't have to be the thing
that you're doing next year,
or in three, or five years.
You can always start something now.
And then, you can still
keep those other ideas,
and do 'em later.
There's no statue of
limitations, or time limit,
on when you can do an idea.
Obviously, there's the market changes,
and people move in, and move out.
But, those ideas are yours.
Like, I still want to learn
how to play the piano,
and I just don't have time right now.
But, it's on my list.
And I will learn, before I die.
But, I'm not, you know,
(stammers) I might not start
for the next ten years.
But, that's fine.
So, just keep those ideas
in your back pocket.
Work on one that seems to
be the easiest to get to,
right now.
And then, keep going.
- [Evan] I like it.
Dion is saying,
"The more that I'm listening to this,
"the more I'm being
confident that I'll make it.
"Thanks, Evan and Daniel."
Oh, "Thanks Evan, and big ups, to Daniel.
"You should run for office someday."
- Oh!
Okay.
This is also the first time I've ever,
you're gettin' a lot of exclusives.
I have a goal, by...
By, by 20 years.
So, I guess that would be
20, well, I'll say by 2040,
to run for Senate.
Yeah.
Because, millennials will be
the politicians of that time.
And by then, everyone who runs for office,
will have had a long-term
public Facebook page,
so there's nothing we can hide.
And they're going to know all
my dirty laundry before I run.
So, I won't have to hide anything.
So, I can just run as myself.
- Well, breaking news.
I love it.
You heard it here first!
- [Daniel] Yeah, seriously.
Haven't talked about that.
- [Evan] I like it.
Oleg wants to know, maybe this ties in,
Oleg wants to know,
"What is your big dream?"
- [Daniel] A big dream.
My big dream, well, do you mean right now,
or do you mean global, like, overall?
Right now, my big dream
is to reduce the anxiety
that this book launch is causing me.
(Evan laughing)
It's so much, it's just
so much, so much, so much,
so much, so much.
But...
That's a really good question, man.
You know what?
I think that my big dream keeps changing.
When I was a kid, I
wanted to be an FBI agent.
Now, that's not one of my big dreams.
I am not tied to the idea
that I have to have one
target my whole life.
This is a big dream.
And just because this book
will have been published,
and it's out now, doesn't mean
that I don't look at this,
and really, really cherish
having been able to do this.
And I always am setting new dreams.
I don't have one.
I don't want to be an astronaut.
I don't have one big milestone in my life.
I also don't think that's a
drawback, or to my detriment.
I think it's great to have,
like, one of my dreams is, for a summer,
I want to be shredded.
Is that not good enough?
I want to just be jacked!
I have little milestone
goals, milestone dreams.
What's your big dream?
Don't talk about my dream.
What's your dream?
- [Evan] Oh, flippin' it on 'em.
I like it.
- [Daniel] Flippin' it.
- I like it, I like it.
Cool, well, it's crazy how
quickly time goes, man!
It's been awesome talkin' to you.
Everybody watchin', I want you
to go to Rich20Something.com.
The book is just slash book, right?
- [Daniel] Yeah!
- Rich20Something.com/book.
You go check it out.
It drops Tuesday.
Daniel, last message of the day.
This is it.
This is your time to wrap it
all up, into a nice bow for us,
and leave us on a high.
What do ya got, man?
- Well, I can't leave you quite at a high,
'cause I'm in North
Carolina, and not California,
but I will tell you this!
(sighs) When everyone else doubts ya...
When you're havin' trouble
seein' the end of the tunnel...
When you're workin' hard, or something,
and it's not workin' out...
You just got to believe.
(Evan laughing)
- And you know that's going
to hit with this audience!
- [Daniel] You just got to believe!
- [Evan] That's it, man!
I love it!
Guys, go check it out.
We'll link it up in the description, too.
Daniel, good luck with the lodge, man!
Thanks for spending some time.
Continue to believe, everybody!
I'mma see ya soon!
- [Daniel] Have a good one!
Peace out, man.